[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Hörer hier sind wir wieder
Mirko Kasimir und Toni Heyer und wir
beginnen unsere heutige Geschichte im
Oktober 1945 in Israel der Zweite
Weltkrieg ist noch nicht mal ein halbes
Jahr vorbei Juden aus aller Welt wollen
nach den Schrecken der Shoah ins gelobte
Land Israel gibt es zu diesem Zeitpunkt
nicht als richtigen Staat das Gebiet
heißt offiziell Palästina und wird von
der sogenannten mandatsmarkt
Großbritannien verwaltet wer sich hier
niederlassen will muss sich das von den
Engländern genehmigen lassen und wer auf
einen Bescheid wartet oder schon
abgelehnt wurde der wird in Lagern
interniert in Lagern wie dem von atlit
südlich der Küstenstadt reifer
[Musik]
das Gelände ist mit einem
Stacheldrahtzaun umgeben und mit
Wachtürmen geschützt wer neu im Lager
ankommt wird mit Fingerabdruck
registriert musst du duschen und wird
desinfiziert für Männer und Frauen gibt
es getrennte Baracken in denen je 30
Leute unterkommen im Oktober 1945 sind
ja hunderte Juden eingesperrt die von
dort aus wieder deportiert werden soll
für den jungen Soldaten
itzrak Rabin und seine Kameraden in der
Widerstandsgruppe Palmach ist das eine
unerträgliche Aussicht sie fassen den
Plan die Inhaftierten zu befreien im
Schutz der Dunkelheit nähern sich die
jüdischen meditioniere dem Lager auf
geheimer Absprachen hin haben Lage in
saßen zuvor den Stacheldrahtzaun
aufgeschnitten und die Waffen der
arabischen Wächter untauglich gemacht so
kommen die Befreiung ohne großen
Widerstand auf das barackengelände
Wecken die Insassen und können mit ihnen
die Flucht antreten
Rabins Frau Lea erinnert sich später so
die erste Schwierigkeit lag darin die
Überlebenden so schnell wie möglich in
die bereitstehenden Fluchtfahrzeuge zu
schaffen
anschließend musste die Gruppe über den
bergkamel geführt werden wobei die paar
machtkämpfer viele von ihnen namentlich
die Kinder huckepackt über den Berg
trugen als die Briten den Bauernhof der
als Zwischenstation vorgesehen war
durchsuchen wollten da strömten tausende
von Juden aus reifer herbei sie
errichteten menschliche Barrikaden und
mischten sich unter die Holocaust
Überlebenden so waren die Briten außer
Stande die befreiten Flüchtlinge aus der
Menge auszusammeln die Operation war ein
durchschlagender Erfolg
der Erfolg eines Mannes der sein Leben
lang für sein Land kämpft der beinhart
kämpfen kann und später trotzdem
versteht dass Siegen nicht alles ist wir
erzählen euch heute das Leben von itzra
krabin weil sein Tod schlimme Folgen
hatte und wir haben wieder Antonia Jamin
als Unterstützung die uns schon bei der
Episode über das Olympia Attentat mit
ihrer Expertise geholfen hat also der
Ermordung von Isra grabin ist für die
Israelis das was nine eleven für die
Amerikaner ist jeder egal wie alt war
sogar wenn er Kind war weiß genau wo er
war und Wasser genau getan hat als
Israel bin erschossen worden ist in
meinem Fall die Familie war zu Hause wir
haben genau im Fernsehen gesehen das war
damals die erste israelische Seifenoper
das hieß Ramada wie viel mal und wir
saßen alle vom Fernsehen als plötzlich
die Sendung unterbrach und man mit der
breaking news kam der Premierminister
jetzt gerade wurde erschossen 40 Minuten
später ist er dann auch gestorben meine
Mutter meine deutsche Mutter die damals
noch nicht mal zehn Jahre in Israel
gewesen war fing an zu heulen ich habe
dann angefangen zu weinen weil ich
verstanden habe wenn meine Mama heult
heißt es dass das was richtig
Schreckliches passiert ist und dann hat
sie mir auch erzählt was der
Premierminister erschossen worden ist
und wer genau war und was seine Pläne
eigentlich waren
Petra grabin wird am 1 märz 1922 in
Jerusalem geboren die Stadt und der Rest
Palästinas werden seit dem Untergang des
Osmanischen Reiches von den Briten
verwaltet schon sein Vater eine hemia
rabien der zeitweise in den USA lebte
war glühender Verfechter eines Staates
Israel im Ersten Weltkrieg diente er als
Freiwilliger in der jüdischen Legion der
britischen Armee danach zu keiner
Jerusalem und lernte dort seine spätere
Frau Rosa kennen das Paar heiratete 1921
sie bekamen außer
RAG 1927 noch eine Tochter Rache
wird nach dem Abi erstmal Landwirt und
arbeitet in einem der bauernkollektive
die man in Israel kebot nennt aber dort
begeisterte er sich schon frühzeitig für
den militärischen Kampf für einen
Einsatz zu Gunsten der israelischen
Sache
und diese Sache ist im 20 Jahrhundert
eine komplizierte Angelegenheit
versuchen wir ein bisschen Ordnung in
die Geschichte zu bekommen von einer
Geschichte Israels kann man ab dem Jahr
1500 vor Christus sprechen vieles davon
kennt man aus der Bibel aber da wir kein
geschichtspodcast sind machen wir einen
Riesensprung von der Zerstörung des
zweiten Tempels in Jerusalem im Jahr 70
bis in die Neuzeit seit 1897 setzt sich
die sogenannte zionistische Bewegung für
einen modernen israelischen Staat ein
noch während die Region zum Osmanischen
Reich gehört also unter der Herrschaft
türkischer Monarchen wandern Juden ein
und Gründen landwirtschaftliche
kooperativen sie teilen sich das Land
mit den Arabern die schon lange hier
sind im Zentrum solcher Höfe wird 1909
auch die Stadt Tel Aviv gegründet nach
dem Ersten Weltkrieg übernimmt
Großbritannien die Verwaltung und stimmt
1917 einen Plan für so etwas wie
Staat Israel zu später will London davon
nichts mehr wissen und während in Europa
mit der Shoa die Vernichtung von Juden
industriell betrieben wird kommt es im
Palästina zu arabischen Aufständen
Palästinenser attackieren von 1936 bis
39 ihre jüdischen Nachbarn und selbst
nach Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges müssen
die Juden weiter auf ihren eigenen Staat
warten England will sich zwar von seinem
Mandat zurückziehen aber wie soll das
Land aufgeteilt werden zwischen Juden
und Arabern
noch im Winter beschließt die
UN-Generalversammlung die Teilung
Palästinas in einen arabischen und einen
jüdischen Staat dafür gibt es damals
unter den Juden durchaus Befürworter
aber die Araber lehnen den Plan ab
überhaupt gibt es in diesen turbulenten
Zeiten mehrere Konfliktlinien aus dem
jüdischen Widerstand heraus werden
Attacken auf arabische Einrichtungen
gestartet gleichzeitig während die
Zionisten sich gegen die britische
verwaltungsmacht und es gibt
Abspaltungen innerhalb der jüdischen
Kräfte die zionistische
Untergrundorganisation nennt sich Hagana
ihre Elitetruppe ist die Palmach von der
Hagana spaltet sich wiederum die ihre
gun ab
mittendrin in all diesen Konflikten
sucht extra
während des Unabhängigkeitskrieges
kämpft er für die Palmach gegen die
Briten bis 1948 endlich Israel gegründet
wird am 14 mai verließt Staatsgründer
David Ben Gurion die israelische
Unabhängigkeitserklärung und noch in
derselben Nacht erklären Ägypten
Saudi-Arabien Jordanien Libanon Irak und
Syrien Israel den Krieg
militärisch aber Sieg das neue kleine
Land recht deutlich in einem Krieg der
15 Monate lang dauert vergrößert Israel
dass ihm zugewiesene Staatsgebiet um 50%
nach diesem Sieg aber verschärft sich
die Spaltung innerhalb der Juden die
Hagana versinkt ein Schiff mit Waffen an
Bord das für die abtrünnigen ihre guten
auf dem Weg ist
kaum gegründet steht das Land am Rande
eines Bürgerkriegs
tragrabinen übersteht alle Krisen dieser
Zeit und macht schließlich Karriere in
der neu gegründeten Armee Israels
außerdem gründete eine Familie mit
seiner Ehefrau leer
die beiden treffen sich zum ersten Mal
1943 vor einer Eisdiele in Tel Aviv da
geht Lea gerade noch in die zehnte
Klasse später schwärmt sie ich glaubte
eine Reinkarnation des biblischen Königs
David vor mir zu haben allerdings war
sein Haar kastanienbraun und seine Augen
waren grau grün und unglaublich
strahlend am meisten aber beeindruckte
mich dass er das typische Verhalten
eines palmarkkämpfers zeigte er
verschwand plötzlich wochenlang und
tauchte dann ebenso plötzlich wieder auf
1948 heiraten die beiden das Paar
bekommt zwei Kinder Tochter Dalia und
Sohn jual rabbins Karriere in der Armee
verläuft steil hier einige Wegmarken
1949 ist der Verhandlungsführer bei
Friedensgesprächen mit Ägypten
1952 erhält er eine Führungsausbildung
in England
1964 wird der generalstaatschef der
Armee in der sinai-krise und dem
Sechstagekrieg wird Rabin zum
Nationalhelden auf dem Gipfel der
Militärlaufbahn wechselt rabbin in die
Politik und wird Botschafter seines
Landes in den USA in diesem Amt kommt
der gut mit den Amerikanern klar und gut
mit der israelischen Regierungschefin
goldami ihr wenn euch dieser Name jetzt
nicht bekannt vorkommt dann habt ihr
vielleicht unsere Doppelfolge über das
olympia-abend hat noch nicht gehört also
lohnt sich auf jeden Fall da auch mal
rein zu hören
für itakrabin geht es in der Politik
steilaufwärts nach der Botschaft der
Zeit zieht er für die Linke
Arbeiterpartei ins Parlament ein und
wird 1974 zum ersten Mal Regierungschef
dafür muss er sich gegen seinen
parteiinternen Konkurrenten Shimon Perez
durchsetzen rabbin und Peres gehören von
nun an zum Stammpersonal von Israels
Politik
rabbins erste Amtszeit endet zwar mit
einer Wahlniederlage gegen die
Konservativen aber schon bald ist er
Verteidigungsminister einer
Koalitionsregierung auf rabbin ist
Verlass nur trotz alle politischen und
militärischen Erfolge ist zu keinem
Zeitpunkt wirklich Frieden in sich
zwischen den Israelis und Palästinensern
die von der plu vertreten werden und
rabien zählt lange Jahre zu den
Hardlinern
beim ersten palästinenseraufstand der
sogenannten Intifada sagt er 1988 wir
sollten ihre Hände und Beine brechen er
wird deshalb noch lange Zeit
Knochenbrecher genannt erst in seiner
zweiten Amtszeit als Ministerpräsident
wird aus dem Falken langsam eine Taube
1993 im Sommer kommt es zum ersten
direkten Gespräch zwischen Vertretern
der PLO und der israelischen Regierung
1994 ist es ausgerechnet der
Knochenbrecher der sein Land anfangs mit
der Waffe in der Hand aufgebaut hat es
ist extra kabin der eine Friedenslösung
mit den Palästinensern erreicht hier
hörte ihn in einem
interviewice
and ich bin wirklich privilegiert dass
ich zu dir Generation Juden gehöre die
das Schicksal in die eigene Hand nehmen
kann
andererseits bin ich mir im Klaren über
die Verantwortung meine Generation hat
und die besonders ich als Regierungschef
habe ich glaube dass ich für uns eine
einmalige Gelegenheit bietet eine dieser
Gelegenheiten wie Sie unser Gründervater
und erster Ministerpräsident davidon
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg hatte
in diesen Tagen gehen historische Bilder
um die Welt
Friedensverhandlungen auf dem us-land
sitzt Camp David die Unterzeichnung des
Abkommens von Oslo
itracrabin und plu-chef Arafat die den
Friedensnobelpreis entgegennehmen aber
um es zu spoilern weder dieser Versuch
eines Friedens noch die nächsten haben
Erfolg im Gegenteil am 4 november 1995
tritt Isa grabin bei einer großen
Kundgebung auf dem Platz der Könige
Israels in Tel Aviv auf die
Veranstaltung steht unter dem Motto ja
zum Frieden Nein zur Gewalt
[Musik]
guten Abend gute Woche ich muss zugeben
dass ich heute abend auch aufgeregt bin
ich möchte mich bei jedem einzelnen von
euch bedanken der sich hier gegen die
Gewalt und für den Frieden eingesetzt
hat
[Musik]
nach seiner Rede verlässt rabbin die
Bühne und wird zu seinem Auto geleitet
der Student egal an mir zockt eine
halbautomatische Pistole Typ der Retter
84f
Projektile hat Amirs Bruder mit Stahl
ummantel damit Sie möglichst viel
Schaden anrichten der Attentäter schießt
dreimal und trifft Sabine tödlich er
stirbt kurz darauf im Krankenhaus
[Musik]
Fernsehen mit der Tagesschau
[Applaus]
[Musik]
guten Abend meine Damen und Herren
Israel trauert und itzra kravin der
Ministerpräsident ist gestern Abend auf
einer grundgebung in Tel Aviv von einem
fanatischen jungen Juden mit mehreren
Schüssen tödlich verletzt worden Amir
wird noch am Schauplatz des Verbrechens
verhaftet am 27 März 1996 verurteilt ihn
das Bezirksgericht telavia zu einer
lebenslangen Freiheitsstrafe wegen
Mordes
Israel ist geschockt und viele fragen
sich warum der Inlandsgeheimdienst
schienenbett den großen Politiker so
ungeschützt herumlaufen ließ aber das
war eben eine andere Zeit meint
bild-reporterin Antonia Jamin
also man muss erstens was verstehen dass
die Sicherheitslage und die
sicherheitsrealität in 1995 eine ganz
andere war der schienbit glaubt du
überhaupt nicht dass ein Jude ein
Premierminister ermorden kann dieser
Premierminister war ein ehemaliger
Verteidigungsminister er war der Chef
der IDF da israelische Armee er war ein
Kriegsheld keiner glaubte dass ein Jude
so ein Mann umbringen könnte und damals
war es so dass es keine sterile Zone gab
um den Premierminister quasi jeder von
der Bevölkerung wenn er möchte konnte
ihm eine Ohrfeige geben der hatte
einfach Pass Security Männer um sich
herum und was egal an ihre gemacht hat
er kam mit einer Waffe zu dieser
Veranstaltung in Tel Aviv zu einem
unkontrolliertes Gebiet keiner hat den
kontrolliert man hat ihn dann einmal
gefragt wer sei und er meinte er ist der
Fahrer von dem Sänger gerade auf der
Bühne steht und keiner hat hinterfragt
und als dann die Veranstaltung vorbei
war und nichts hat gerade in überholt
hat niemand die Waffe und hat ihn in den
Rücken geschossen so was konnte heute in
Israel auf keinen Fall passieren also
keiner von der Bevölkerung kann einfach
an den Premierminister heran also heute
gibt es eine sterile Zone heute wird man
kontrolliert keiner kann mit einer Waffe
überhaupt nah an den Premierminister und
das hat sich alles geändert seitdem die
weltraut um israk Rabin allen voran auch
der damalige US-Präsident Clinton
ein halbes Jahrhundert lang hat Isak
Rabin sein Land verteidigt heute hat er
sein Leben geopfert um ihm dauerhaften
Frieden zu bringen
[Musik]
den gibt es bis heute nicht und das
Fazit von Antonia Jamin das fällt auch
nicht besonders rosig aus
also ich werde so sagen aus der
Perspektive von 28 Jahren nach dem Mord
kann man sagen dass der Mord erfolgreich
war also er erreichte sein politisches
Ziel denn politischen und historischen
Prozess zwischen Israel und den
Palästinenser zu stoppen in vielerlei
Hinsicht hat sich das liberale und
demokratische Lager in Israel von diesem
Mord nicht erholt also bis heute ist es
wie eine offene Wunde bis heute spricht
man noch in den Medien darüber also
dieser Mord war ja am Endeffekt ein
richtiger Schlag in den Magen von viele
Israel ist weil das war der Moment in
dem die Israelis verstanden habe dass
eigentlich auch ein Jude ein Terrorist
sein kann
und damit sind wir am Ende einer sehr
politischen Episode unseres True Crime
Podcasts schreibt uns gern eure Meinung
unter podcast@bild.de für die heutige
Ausgabe überlassen wir Antonia das sehr
politische Schlusswort also heute sind
ja die extremes Persönlichkeiten die
damals gegen Israel bin vorgingen Teil
der Regierung also die sind Minister in
der Regierung die sitzen im Kabinett es
gibt es denn wenn wir wenn wir hat ein
paar Tage vor dem Mord von Israel bin er
kam an seinem Auto und hat sein
Autoschild runtergenommen und wenn wir
damals schon gesagt so wie wir haben ins
Auto gekommen sind werden wir auch an
Israel Krabben selbst kommen und ein
paar Tage danach hat man ermordet dieser
Mann
der sogar noch nicht mal in die IDF kam
in die israelische Armee weil
israelischer mir wollte ihn nicht weil
er einen Unterstützer von
Terrororganisation war ist heute ein
Minister in Israel er sitzt im Kabinett
der ist der Polizei Minister seine
Aufgabe ist die Sicherheit im Inland zu
schützen so eine Geschichte kann man so
schlecht noch nicht mal schreiben ein
anderer
extremistisch er hat erst vor paar
Wochen gesagt dass man ein ganzes
arabisches Dorf verbrennen muss dieser
Mann es Wirtschaftsminister
das war es jetzt aber wirklich für heute
die Redaktion hatten Stefan Netzeband
und Antonia Jamin die Postproduktion
kamen wie immer von wakewide München bis
zum nächsten mal eure Toni und eure
Merkur